.
YOU ARE EARTHBOUND.
YOU ARE NOT TRANSPHOBIC.
AIR TRAVEL IS A DISASTER UNDER
THE MAN THAT IS SUPPOSED TO FIX
AIR TRAVEL.
HAVE YOU RIDDEN ON A TRAIN
RECENTLY?
MONDAY 5:00 P.M., PASSENGERS IN
VIRGINIA.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO ARRIVE --
THEY WERE STUCK ON THE TRAIN FOR
37 HOURS, AMTRAK PART OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM COULDN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
AROUND A DERAILMENT.
SOME PASSENGERS CALLED THE
POLICE THINKING THEY HAD BEEN
TAKEN HOSTAGE.
>> FOR THOSE OF YOU CALLING THE
POLICE, WE ARE GIVING YOU ALL
THE INFORMATION.
WE ARE SORRY ABOUT THE
INCONVENIENCE.
AS SOON AS THE INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE, WE'LL LET YOU KNOW
SHORTLY.
THANK YOU.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT HOLDING
YOU HOSTAGE.
WE HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION IN
QUOTE IN WHICH WE HAVE.
[LAUGHTER].
EXCUSE ME.
THAT IS OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
PROBABLY NOT FUNNY IF YOU WERE
ON THE SYSTEM.
COLLEEN, SORRY TO LAUGH MUST
HAVE BEEN HORRIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
>> EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING LACK OF
INFORMATION FROM AMTRAK.
I WOKE UP AT 6:00 A.M. TUESDAY.
WE WERE STOPPED IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
I SPOKE WITH ONE OF MY
ATTENDANTS.
HE SAID DERAILMENT IN A TRAIN IN
FRONT OF US.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHEN WE ARE
ARRIVING IN SANFORD MY BEST
GUESS IS LATER THIS EVENING.
THEY HAD NO IDEA.
>> Tucker: TRAINS, CORRECT ME IF
I AM WRONG THEY ARE ON TRACKS.
THEY CAN'T VEER OFF INTO THE
WOODS AND GET LOST.
THEY RUN ON METAL RAILS.
AT LEAST THAT IS THE WAY IT USED
TO WORK.
HOW COULD A TRAIN NOT HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE IT IS
GOING?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
AT ONE POINT WE MOVED TO SOUTH
CAROLINA.
WE WERE STUCK THERE FOR SIX
HOURS.
THEY TOLD US THEY NEEDED TO
SWITCH OVER CREWS.
ONE SHOULD BE ARRIVING AT AROUND
5:30.
5:30 CAME AROUND.
THEY WERE UNSURE OF WHERE THE
CREW WOULD YOU SAY, NEXT UPDATE
7:30.
>> Tucker: WERE YOU CONFUSED
WHEN THEY SAID THEY ARE NOT
HOLDING YOU HOSTAGE?
>> THERE WAS NO WAY OFF OF THE
TRAIN.
WE WERE STUCK IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
THERE WASN'T AN OPTION TO GO
OUTSIDE.
WE WERE LOCKED IN, I DIDN'T FEEL
UNSAFE.
>> Tucker: DID ANYONE TRY TO
MAKE A BREAK FOR IT?
>> NOT THAT I AM AWARE OF.
COULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: HMM, I HAVE TO ASK,
THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT
RACISM, MISOGYNY AND TRANSPHOBIA
IN OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM DID
YOU NOTICE ANY OF THOSE THINGS
ON THE AMTRAK TRAIN 1234?
>> WHEN I WAS AROUND OTHER
PEOPLE I DIDN'T NOTICE ANYTHING
SIGNIFICANT.
>> Tucker: I THI